last week Wendy filed for divorce and
she's not the only one who just took a
big step toward singlehood so did Brad
and Angelina both Brad and Angelina are
now single and free to remarry someone
else a judge ruled their marriage is
officially over
more than two and a half years after she
filed for divorce while they continue to
finalize details in their divorce a
source reports to et that Brad and Angie
have come a long way to the surprise of
many of their closest friends their
communication has improved tremendously
they rarely argue now and are now at a
point where they can discuss their
children's plans calmly the source also
says they're both dedicated to
co-parenting and now the kids spend time
with both their parents and are happy
and thriving
moving on to wedding news Dancing with
the Stars Bow Markovski and Jenna
Johnson type in not Saturday at the
Terranea Resort South Los Angeles the
bride wore a fitted white dress with a
sheer turtleneck and sleeves from
designer Vera Wang the couple's first
dance was to Le'Veon robes I think a lot
of people expect us to do it big
choreographed dance and we're just gonna
plug in vows best man brother Mac shared
a smooch with wife pita as their son
Shai was a part of the ceremony among
the guests vows former partner Olympic
gymnast Lauri Hernandez recently at a
cake tasting the newlyweds told UT about
their baths we are writing her when I
say why
[Music]
[Applause]